DMITRY KULIKOV TO ALEX CHIASSON.
TUCKER POOLMAN IN FRONT OF HIM.
DOMINIK KAHUN IN FRONT OF HIM
BUT THE JETS HAVE THE PUCK AND
HERE THEY COME.
IT'S ANDREW COPP TO STASTNY.
STASTNY A SHOT AND THEY SCORE!
STASTNY!
AND THE WINNIPEG JETS TAKE A
COMMANDING 2-0 SERIES LEAD HERE
IN OVERTIME!
>> Louie: YOU JUST GOT THE
FEELING IT WAS GOING TO BE A
GOAL JUST LIKE THIS.
IT WAS A HIGH SHOT FROM THE SLOT
BY STASTNY THAT HAD EYES FOR THE
TOP CORNER OF THE GLOVE HAND
SIDE.
BUT IT WAS THE  FLY BY IN FRONT
BY MIKE SMITH, THE LITTLE
PARTIAL SCREEN THAT TAKES HIS
EYES AWAY FOR THAT SPLIT SECOND
AND FIND ITS WAY INTO THE BACK
OF THE NET.
YOU COULD TELL THE PACE THAT
BOTH OF THESE TEAMS CAME OUT IN
OVERTIME THIS WASN'T GOING TO
LAST LONG.
THERE WAS TOO MUCH END TO END,
TOO MANY CHANCES AROUND THE NET.
AND THE GRIZZLED VETERAN PAUL
STASTNY WHO PLAYED HIS
THOUSANDth GAME THIS YEAR IN
THE NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE WITH
A HUGE GOAL THIS OVERTIME.
>> Harnarayan: STASTNY TOOK
THAT PENALTY AS WELL LATE IN THE
THIRD.
AND NOW HE IS THE HERO.
>> Louie: RIGHT THERE THE
LITTLE DROP PASS BY COPP.
FUNNELS THROUGH TO THE NET AND
MAYBE SCREENED BY LARSSON TOO.
FOR COPP HE GOES RIGHT THROUGH
AND USES BOTH THE SCREENS.
SCREEN OF KULIKOV AND SCREEN OF
LARSSON AND FINDS ITS WAY RIGHT
TO THE TOP CORNER.
WATCH THIS ANGLE RIGHT THROUGH.
IT MIGHT HAVE EVEN BEEN TICKED
ON BUT FINDS ITS